[Music]
welcome to another vlog
i'm back baby
shirtless vlogging
i've been sick
i think we had covered it wasn't so bad
i had like 37 degrees fever for two days
and the whole time i was like i'm dying
help me matzia and then marseille got
sick sorry marcia and she had really
high fever
so we've been kind of just
self-isolating basically i've been free
for it for a while so i'm back working
out it's funny looking back because i i
was like i'm not feeling good today guys
like yeah no i was sick that's why i
need to learn to listen to my body i
guess but it feels good to be back look
how cute my ears
she loves to bury her face
we met up with a really good vet here
which felt really nice
uh edgar had some skin problems that
they really helped out with
okay so
one
two
three
four five
it looks pretty clean
oh she's waking it
been adding some details
hanged up my uh painting
this is from my granddad he passed away
many years ago but he's the one that got
me into reading when i was really young
i was really into sherlock holmes book
books thanks to him but i didn't really
get into really reading until like
a couple years ago and i always felt
like it's such a shame he wasn't alive i
would love to like talk to him about all
the books i read because he read every
single book there is even wrote a book
about books
that's still being published
just thought it made sense next to my
library
[Music]
i'm going to a surf shop i tried to buy
one online but they canceled my order
i'm always a bit nervous going to like
hobby shops because sometimes they can
be kind of like stingy we'll check it
out
i want to go surfing again
mine stays away today so
it's just me and the puggies they're
sitting next to me
look at you guys
so cute
[Music]
got the surfboard
he was so helpful i'm so glad i actually
bought it in a shop
because he was explaining all about it
super cool board i'm super excited about
it aren't you maya
there's my beautiful
hell yeah baby i love this car
we're going to pick up the board now
[Music]
i'm walking past marzia
i want to see if eggy notices
[Music]
he did not
[Music]
we're at the city hall
mars is already waiting she's going to
get her my number which is like a
tax number i'm not entirely sure what it
is but like it's pretty daunting but
they're taking such good care of us
i'm amazed by this building
[Music]
it's a cool area
this is like a
sports stadium i think how we doing here
maya
come on
come on iggy
what a bunch of nerds that walk am i
right maya
this is how it's done you're enjoying
the walk maya
she wants food
well you hungry
there you are
oh ew
he's shaking his booty
damn
let's zoom on this camera though
oh you shy
mars is getting an ice cream oh this
just landed on me is that a stink bug
can you leave please
nice hey guys like mine
it's a bean flavor
i mean really
cheese
love it
everyone my he's so tired
check this out
just arrived
gonna hang it up it's a little taller
than i would have liked
i'm
gonna cut it down
make it a better size
that doesn't look too bad
are we a little crazy today man
it's okay
is how she becomes
a knight
it takes a long time to calm down
and now she's a sweetheart
[Music]
hello
i'm going out to meet uh connor and i'm
meeting up with chris brother for the
first time we're doing like a day hang
just going out for lunch then i don't
know what we're doing to be honest i
told marzan she was like have fun on
your little date it's not a date
[Music]
three
two
one go
hold it hold it hold it
it gets harder it gets harder
oh
no
he is technically cheating it should be
one hand let's be told off oh no
oh my god
it's surprisingly tame he's done this
before
i guess that's enough
what
he's got no size strength oh my god what
it's a table flip game i've looked
everywhere for these
[Music]
it's so violently loud
[Music]
yeah
home run
where are you going
yeah
first hang out with chris good dude i
met connor before he's a great guy
that was really fun
i had a really good time it's obviously
like you move to a new country there's
new people
but i'm glad they're both really really
good dudes make me happy heading back
home now to look at this view it's so
crazy i have no idea where i am
and tomorrow i'm going surfing again get
to try on my surfboard i'm so excited
got her waxed up
tomorrow we're going out
i am so excited
oh wow you're so japanese
[Music]
[Music]
look at this
it's so professional now
we're going to the beach today
this time i'm prepared what do you say
about me
are you saying about the sweet listen to
this beautiful sound
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready first time alone
[Music]
[Music]
whenever we go to the beach maya just
completely crashes
yes
marzia made
with love
[Music]
she's covered by clouds but you can see
mount fuji
over there
[Music]
hello my fuji how you doing that was
great
caught a couple of ways more than i ever
done i didn't get there all on found
because i messed it up but there wasn't
a couple of good ones
what's going on here
are you looking for marzian
what you doing
where's marcia there she is okay she's
there do you see her
there she is
you see her we just did a quick uh stop
at the beach only two hours and now
we're heading back not a bad way to
start the day
[Music]
sheesh
[Music]
i'm naked
[Music]
i started taking cold showers
because it's supposed to be good for
like muscle pain here we go
[Music]
so
some of you guys
saw in my uh last vlog i was reading the
player handbook you're correct i'm
playing dnd
it's been so fun i love it i actually
played in the the first time seven years
ago with matt mercer who's like
the indie legend which is really cool uh
but then
ken
has played a lot since then and he's
he's uh
dming
and he's a really good dm actually so
we've been playing the group with all my
friends in uk
jack pj dave's joined i think i think
jonas and joel will join as well it's
just super fun i can't believe i never
played it earlier i'm playing uh
tiefling warlock and who's
chaotic good whenever i explain about
characters to marzia or what it did to
me it's like so cool but i can just hear
just how lame it is but yeah my
character is uh deeply more like cold so
ugly and he wants to afford facial
reconstruction surgery and he terrorizes
anyone that we try and save it's so
funny let's just say i'm the chaotic
element to the party i love it such a
fun game we probably won't film it we're
just playing it for fun and uh honestly
having a blast an eldritch blast to say
it
how are you doing today ma'am you're
doing good one thing actually you know i
talked about maya's health a lot in the
vlogs but one thing that
has significantly
improved with maya is that she hasn't
had any stomach issues
she used to have it at least once a
month where she's just in so much pain
that she would cry out and we can't
sleep this is a horrible time
she hasn't had it a single time since we
moved here
so
knock on wood maya
it doesn't happen i don't know what
changed it's kind of insane to be honest
she's had it her entire life so yeah fun
times get the surf play d d
it's great
we just saw lightning it was so cool
i wanna see it again
come on lightning whoa
we saw one where the light just like
went all the way out it was so cool